Mitch Kessler my co-host and partner of
15 years was fired today for sexual
misconduct
I've only been running the news
about
this is a good time to start grooming
some new people chip you are the ep the
show is slipping on your watch the only
thing keeping us afloat is me we are
doing this my way my new Morning Show
co-host is Bradley Jackson I think most
people want to trust the person telling
them about the world is an honest person
like you
yes
I want to produce her why we're in the
middle of an epic rebirth it's kind of
exciting well you're excited did you
know it's about match we have someone
who could corroborate Network complicity
you have evidence against the head of
this company
are we doing this yeah we would like to
share some information about our Network
corporate culture comes from the top
down we cannot accept a culture of
Silence
oh gosh we have to stay together on this
[Music]
guy asks me to look after you but I
don't think you need it
my brother's having a really hard time
you need to go now
no I'm on your side always
I love you
Maggie Brenner's book is coming up
there's going to be some damning
information in there I'm done you do
hold the network accountable but why
rope Alex into it we risked our careers
just to get the truths out there
Alex you earned a connection to the
women of this country I'm here as a
result you open a door and you need to
walk through it now
Fred is planning nasty stories in the
Press we can stop them the only thing
that moves the needle is an even more
salacious story you know who's dating
Laura Peterson and Bradley Jackson
I'm underneath proof
I don't want my private life public I
need you to release a statement you and
me never happened
yeah you should look at this
Mitch Kessler has tragically died
that was only put in charge after
failure is certain I'm trying to help
don't undermine my authority I tested
positive for covet I'm barely hanging on
right now the network wants you on the
air what could be more informative than
watching Alex get through it what if she
doesn't get through it do you really
think this is about your television
network this is a battle for the soul of
the universe
stay tuned
[Music]